[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Coulson tonight i'm brian kill me a big
treat for you this evening
tucker dubbed him the creepy porn lawyer
and tonight
CPL is making a return to prime time
he'll be right here straight ahead he
won't be able to see it i believe he's
in jail
but first millions of americans were
forced to make major sacrifices during
the coronavirus lockdowns maybe you
still are at the time we were told the
sacrifice would flatten the curve and it
would save lives business is by the way
we're destroyed unemployment record
highs still at 1.3 million today and now
after months of restrictions the virus
is back and politicians want to do the
exact same thing so sectors that we're
closing stay wide again restaurants
wineries movie theaters family
entertainment zoos museums card rooms
and bars to outdoor activities to the
extent possible now with counties on the
monitoring list we have this list
fitness centers places of worship
offices for non critical sectors
personal care services that includes
hair salons barbershops
and indoor malls the good news is they
had the full screen built already from a
month ago so with so much shutdown
fatigue will people actually obey the
second wave of shutdown some businessmen
like California barber shop owner
Wanda Maris didn't want to obey the
first wave I had read something you told
my producer where you basically said I
don't care if I get it meaning kovat 19
do you do you still feel that way
absolutely I mean a lot of us gonna get
it the statistics out is that we're
we're not gonna most likely we're not
gonna die we have a ninety-nine point
seven percent chance of living whether
we contracted or not now let me let me
jump in and because I think neither of
us are doctors and I know there's a lot
of numbers being thrown out I've had it
it wasn't it was not fun
yeah it's easy one of them is still
getting paid now we saw that interview
and we invited him on to defend his
position they came in here the cops came
in here today and gave us a cease and
desist order from the city of Akko
and abide by it definitely I'm not I'm
gonna continue working them because do
you say open my Barber's you can
continue to work and they're gonna
continue to serve our community do I
expect back bill to come and cite me
absolutely and they're going to you
they've said they're going to you know I
think that there's no plan in place so
I'm just going to be the escape pill for
the city so here we go again facing a
second round of shutdowns the man you
just saw one damaris joins us now one
the news extra specially distressing for
business owners like you what are you
gonna do okay we're gonna stay open and
we're going to you to get serve our
community we're not gonna be bullied
we're not gonna live in fear and we're
we're gonna we're gonna continue on
we're not gonna let this stop us will
your customers come I mean we're booked
solid we're the most busy shop in town
we have people coming from all over the
state in fact we have people coming from
out of the state we're we're booked and
it's it's not slowing down once since
you went back online against the law and
then once they released you to do this
how many of your clients customers
tested positive for the corona virus
well as far as I know none
no one's ever come in told us none of my
barbers have tested positive myself as
intesifies another our family members
have tested positive
I think these these tests are are just
gonna confuse everyone especially for
the fact that our the tests are proving
that the death rate is going down in a
at a great rate I'm there's absolutely
no reason to keep shutting down our
economy shutting our state shutting down
the nation what they say in California
at eight thousand Newt two hundred
eleven cases coming over the past week
what else do you want them to do well
listen if your test more and there's
gonna be more tip there's gonna be more
positive cases that's that's a
statistical fact no one's arguing that
but it's not it's not detrimental to our
health it hasn't been detrimental
the death rate we've lived with with TB
and whooping cough and flus for our
entire you know lives in that's never
shut down the nation before and there's
no reason to shut it down now
the only reason that Gavin Newsom is is
doing this is because he's had a little
taste of power he enjoys it and he's
gonna continue to flex it as much as he
can
hey one how much does gavin newsom get
paid if there's a shutdown I believe
according to our records the same amount
if they shut you down how much do you
get paid I mean we get paid nothing and
there's no worse self employed there's
no unemployment for us there's no PPP in
line for us I mean all these big major
corporations are getting paid and the
little corporations small businesses
they want us to break our backs and not
get paid and step away from what we do
and we're not gonna do that
you know like unfortunately there's no
really good leadership on any and either
of the parties including the Republican
Party I feel like right now the only one
who's using any type of common sense is
President Trump and his uh his White
House staff and unfortunately for us you
know he's not around here so we're gonna
we're gonna make teams stay open if
that's the find that I don't my that's
just you know over the last five months
I've had a chance to talk a lot of small
business people between paying your rent
and paying for paying utilities between
paying your employees taking care of
insurance and workers comp you have your
hands full every day all you want is a
chance to be successful how does it feel
that someone's robbing you of that
chance and telling you you're selfish
for fighting for it to make a living
well listen I'm not gonna be bullied by
anyone including governor Newsom
including all of our senators and
congressmen that are unwilling to make
any stand on this and I tell them you
know I'm not asking for a penny I'm not
asking for a handout and I'm gonna
continue to charge on and I'm not gonna
be bullied it's not the American Way I
hear you want a best of luck we're going
to track you we want you to be safe I
know you gonna stay safe because guess
what if you're not and people start
testing positive they won't come back
which you'll be in control of your own
fate and so far you've done
pretty good job doing that best of luck
thank you